- [Instructor] In the
last video we talk about
the first 200 years of Rome
being an official empire,
starting with Augustus in 27 BCE,
going all the way to Marcus Aurelius,
and that time period is referred to
as Pax Romana, Roman Peace.
It's a relatively stable,
relatively peaceful time for Rome.
Now all of that is relative.
If you're one of the tribes
that are still fighting
with the Roman legions,
if you're one of the roughly 1/4 to 1/3
of the population that is a slave,
you might not view this
as such a good time.
But things only get worse
after the death of Marcus Aurelius,
who's viewed as the last
of the five good emperors,
so to speak.
His son, Commodus, takes over,
and Commodus is the beginning
of a succession of emperors
who are less and less competent.
The Empire becomes more and more corrupt,
less and less stable,
and things really come to a head
and start to decelerate even further,
or I guess accelerate downward
even further, in 235 CE
when the emperor Severus
Alexander is assassinated,
and this throws the empire
into a 50-year crisis
called the Third Century Crisis
because it happened in the third century.
And over this 50 years, there's
26 claimants to emperor.
The empire is temporarily split
into three different states.
There's attacks from the
east from the Sassanids,
the Sassanian Empire,
they're the successors
to the Parthians.
You have attacks across
the Rhine and the Danube
from Germanic tribes.
All of that makes this a very
unstable period for Rome.
Now the Third Century
Crisis is considered to end
in 284 with the ascension of Diocletian,
and Diocletian is viewed as a somewhat,
or a reasonably strong emperor.
He's known as the last emperor
that really persecuted the Christians
because they didn't
follow the Roman religion,
they did not worship the emperor as a god,
but he's also, or maybe
he's most famous for
splitting the empire.
He decides that probably
one of the main causes
of the Third Century Crisis is that
the empire has gotten too vast.
It has too many borders.
It's hard for one emperor to
administer the whole thing,
so he splits it into East and West
from an administrative point of view.
They don't become separate empires,
but he decides that he is going to rule
from the East and that he will have
a co-emperor who rules from the West.
And not only does he set that up,
but he sets up what's called a tetrarchy.
Beyond himself and his co-emperor,
they each have a second-in-command
that if any one of them were to die
or would have to retire somehow,
that that second-in-command
could take over,
and once again, this is to
address some of the issues
of the Third Century Crisis where the wars
for succession, and this isn't just during
the Third Century Crisis.
We've seen it in multiple videos.
Rome is famous, even
during the Pax Romana,
for these really ugly succession battles,
but as we'll see, the
splitting of the empire
into East and West, even though it started
as an administrative
thing, over time it's going
to become a real split
and they're going to turn
into two different empires.
Now after Diocletian, you have
another significant emperor.
You have Constantine,
and Constantine is known for many things.
Maybe most famously, he
embraced Christianity,
as opposed to Diocletian
who persecuted Christians,
you have the Council of
Nicaea and the Nicaean Code
where there's now a
uniform church doctrine
around Christianity.
He has the Edict of Milan,
which makes Christianity
legal under Roman rule.
Maybe most famously on his deathbed,
he gets baptized.
He becomes the first Christian emperor.
He also moves the capital to,
officially moves the capital
of the entire empire,
to what at the time was Byzantium,
but then he renames it to Constantinople,
named after him.
Now it was still one unified empire,
even Diocletian who
co-ruled with a co-emperor,
he had veto power over
the emperor to the West.
Now as we get further into
the fourth century here,
and especially into the fifth century,
we'll see that the empire
further and further fragments,
and gets diluted, and
really just breaks down.
One major factor in that breakdown
is in that fourth century, in the fourth
and fifth centuries, you have a group
called the Huns coming
in from Central Asia,
coming in from Northern
Europe right over here,
and they are fierce, nomadic conquerors,
and they're so fierce
that they start pushing
more of the Germanic
tribes across the Rhine
and the Danube, and a lot
of these Germanic tribes,
at first, even though their history
has been fighting the
Romans, a lot of them
try to seek refuge in the Roman Empire
and they're given refuge
in the Roman Empire,
but while they have that refuge,
they're treated very, very, very badly,
and all of that comes to a head in the,
well I guess you could
say, the last quarter
of the fourth century
with the Gothic Wars,
and the Gothic Wars really
have a decisive battle
at Adrianople, originally Adrianopolis,
named after the Emperor Hadrian.
And at Adrianopolis, at Adrianople,
the Gothic tribes in particular,
and when we say Gothic,
we're really talking
about Germanic tribes, and
this one in particular,
as you can see from this
legend right over here,
this is the Visigoths, or Western Goths,
they're able to decisively defeat
the Eastern Roman Emperor Valens.
He's actually killed at Adrianople,
and then the Visigoths just
continue to hang out here
in the Roman Empire.
They continue to move forward.
In 410, they're able to actually sack Rome
and they eventually settle
in the Iberian Peninsula
and in Southern Gaul.
Now after the Battle of Adrianople,
you have another significant
emperor, Theodosius,
because what you'll see is that
Diocletian persecuted Christians,
Constantine now embraces Christianity,
he becomes a Christian, he
says Christianity is legal.
Theodosius now, right
as we are about to enter
into the fifth century,
he makes Christianity
the official religion of the Roman Empire.
So in roughly 100 years, the Roman Empire
went from persecuting Christians
to making it the official religion
and actually going the other way,
starting to persecute some of
the pre-Christian religions
or rituals.
The other thing that happens as we enter
into the fifth century now, as we go into
the fifth century, you have the capital
of the Western Empire is
moved from Rome to Ravenna.
With the idea, the
emperor see all of these
Germanic tribes, they
feel threatened by them,
that Ravenna is easier to defend.
It's surrounded by kind
of marshy, swampy area.
The other thing of note about Theodosius,
and as we move into
really the last century
of the Western Roman Empire, is Theodosius
was the last Roman Emperor
to rule all of Rome.
After that, the East
and West are going to be
ruled essentially independently.
They're essentially going
to be separate empires.
Then as we get into the fifth century,
we already talked about
the Visigoths sacking Rome,
then in 455, you have the Vandals
which is another Germanic tribe that was
similarly originally
pushed out by the Huns.
You see them in blue right over here.
They make it down the Iberian Peninsula
to North Africa.
They eventually get to Carthage,
and they become a little
bit of a naval power
and they eventually are able to, in 455,
sack Rome as well.
So Rome is really taking
a hit multiple times.
And then finally, the
end of the Roman Empire,
or the Western Roman
Empire that most historians
consider the end of the Roman Empire,
is when the Germanic
ruler General Odoacer,
or Odoacker depending
on how you pronounce it,
is able to oust the emperor in Ravenna,
and so then you have the official,
and just to be clear, this
is, let me write Roman Empire,
and so Odoacer is able to essentially
end the Western Empire as we know it.
And after that, the Western Empire
becomes more and more fragmented
into these kingdoms that are ruled by
essentially Germanic
kings, and then we are now
entering into the Middle Ages.
Now the big question that historians
have a lot of fun thinking about
is why did all of this happen?
Why did the Roman Empire fall?
And before we even talk about why it fell,
we should give them a
little bit of credit.
Even in this video where I talk about
the fall of the Roman Empire,
I'm covering 300 years of history,
and if you start with the
founding of the republic
until Odoacer takes over
Ravenna, ousts the emperor,
we're talking 1,000 years.
Most civilizations,
most empires don't last
anywhere near that long.
So to some degree, it's
surprising that it lasted so long.
But in terms of the causes of its decline,
we've talked about several
of them in this video.
The empire got divided.
The East and West stopped
viewing themselves
so much as the same empire.
Trade sometimes broke down.
They didn't support each other militarily.
The Eastern Empire was generally stronger,
so it allowed invading tribes to focus
on the weak point in the West.
Some historians would
say that the Roman Empire
stopped expanding, and
it needed that expansion
in order to keep getting
more land and more slaves
that really drove its economy.
One major factor probably was the Huns
that caused this great
migration in the fourth
and fifth centuries, it
caused the Germanic tribes
to cross the Rhine and cross the Danube
and become either settled as part
of the Roman Empire or
threatened the Roman Empire.
Another theory, and all of
these are probably contributors,
is that as the Germanic tribes settled,
they actually became more and more part of
the Roman military, and some of them were
officially part of the military,
some of them were mercenaries,
soldiers for fortune,
paid soldiers, and so you
can imagine their allegiance
to Rome was not as strong.
Some folks say Christianity
may have been a factor.
That the empire might have lasted,
especially when people were doing
what their traditional rites, rituals,
they worshiped an emperor,
but now Christianity
wasn't about worshiping
an emperor anymore.
A lot of people think it's
corruption, instability,
and we've talked a little bit about that.
It could've been invasions, not just from
the Germanic tribes and the Huns,
but also the Sassanids on the East.
So I'll leave you there,
and to think about,
what was the cause or maybe what allowed
the Roman Empire to survive for so long?